millions of people in Southern
California they're on edge and they are
worried about their safety after two
large earthquakes and more than four
thousand aftershocks
yowza those after shots continue through
the weekend and some were felt more than
a hundred miles away
the powerful damaging quakes rocked the
small desert town of Ridgecrest 110
miles north of Los Angeles some people
there are so concerned they refused to
sleep indoors the second quake magnitude
7.1 was the strongest California has
seen in 20 years CTM lead national
correspondent David Begg know begins our
coverage he's in Ridgecrest near the
epicenter of those two big quakes David
good morning set the scene for us where
you are Tony good morning his Anthony
was saying a lot of people don't want to
sleep in their own homes the aftershocks
keep coming but we're not feeling most
of them but a lot of people are choosing
to sleep outside here outside City Hall
you've got about 25 families that are
sleeping in the tents behind me 20 yards
from where I am is the government
complex that has been transitioned into
a Red Cross shelter you've got about 60
people inside of there and right outside
the shelter some people have opted to
sleep in their own vehicles I want to
give you the context we are in the
middle of the Mojave Desert the middle
of nowhere as some people like to say
Ridgecrest is a city of about 25,000
people the damage here is sparsely
popular in different areas right it's
kind of hard to find had the earthquake
happened in downtown Los Angeles it
would have been catastrophic so were you
to drive around Ridgecrest this morning
it would be hard to find some of the
damage but Carter Evans has and that's
where he is just about five minutes from
where we are Carter good morning David
good morning there is a lot of cleaning
up to do here as you can see this wall
collapsed right up against this home
overall though in Ridgecrest things are
beginning to return to normal roads are
clear water and power is back on though
scientists say aftershocks are going to
rattle this community for a long time
after living through something like this
the shock for residents in and around
Ridgecrest still hasn't worn off how are
you feeling still nervous
it hasn't settled every time the ground
starts shaking
the mine goes back all of these people
up here are here for you today at a town
hall Sunday local officials tried to
reassure the shaking community with the
steps they're taking PTSD is a real
thing and we're all suffering from it
right now we have teams coming in that
will help us with that Friday night's
powerful 7.1 earthquake rocked the
desert town sending items flying off
store shelves and people scrambling when
the seven-point-one quake struck brick
chimneys just didn't stand a chance they
crumbled this one went right through the
roof of the home in the chimney fell and
all of those bricks broke the Joyce's
Marilyn McKee was inside her husband
spent Sunday trying to prevent any more
damage from aftershocks so that's why
you're getting all this stuff off the
roof yeah so it doesn't end up on the
floor of the kitchen this was so
awakening to what an earthquake can
really do flavio Montes and his family
are so rattled they've decided to sleep
outside of a Red Cross shelter we ended
up coming out here because my kids
wouldn't every time that it'll shape
would happen to oh they just sorry
panicking his daughter and her friend
say it'll be a while before they're
ready to return home do you feel safer
out here after two major earthquakes
authorities call it a miracle nobody was
killed or seriously injured we were
built and constructed and planned under
earthquake for cautionary measures and
you think I made a difference I know it
did the good news is the USGS says
there's now just a 1% chance of a seven
magnitude or greater earthquake
occurring in this area also the chance
of a 6r magnitude or greater is also
diminishing David Carter the more time
passes the less likely we'll have
another big one thank you very much